In today's video,
we are going to find
out what happens
when you light a giant
rubber band ball on fire.
[Music]
Guys, we've heard
that some interesting
things happen when you light
a rubber band ball on fire,
so we're going to try
this with a giant one.
That's not very giant.
How many did you add?
2,000.
In case anybody's wondering
about how long this took,
Lord of the Rings Two
Towers Extended Edition.
Here's the idea.
We're going to test burning
out a regular-sized
rubber band ball,
and then we're going
to upgrade to an ultra
sized rubber band ball.
So, here's we're going to do.
We're going to build a fire.
We're going to try putting
our small rubber band ball
into the fire,
but we weren't satisfied
with just seeing it this size.
So that's why we upgraded.
That's true.
But there is a few things
I want to do with this
before we destroy it.
I want to drop it
off of something.
[Music]
All right.
Not even close.
[Music]
Oh, so close.
One more.
Boing!
Yeah.
There we go.
Boing.
So I just remembered something.
I'm afraid of heights.
We've now got a setup
that should be able
to direct some heat right
onto our rubberband ball
for as long as we want.
So we're gonna start
with the little one,
see how that goes,
and then upgrade.
[Music]
And now we run away.
There's no such thing
as too much fire, Nate.
[Music]
There's just not enough tension
on this smaller rubber
band ball to do much,
or to look very cool.
It's just kind of melting.
It's pretty much just
on fire now at this point.
If we used both of these burners,
we're going to get
a lot of fire,
but you're not actually going
to see the rubber bands
themselves snapping.
So we're going to stick
with one burner for now.
See what happens.
[Music]
Already, already!
Yeah, that's going to pop--
Mark, there.
Oh, oh!
There it goes.
This is the world's most
dangerous game of soccer.
Okay, before I put
this back in the fire,
let's take a look
what's happened.
That is probably
400 rubber bands right there.
Oh, this burned
away an entire side.
Can you see that?
You can kind of
see here it burns,
but then they spark,
and when they start to get
a little bit tighter,
they fling in every direction.
This is probably
the hardest layer
for me to do,
just with how tense some
of these rubber bands are.
So hopefully, they
should start flinging off,
and it looks pretty cool.
There. Perfect.
[Music]
So all those little sparks are
flinging pieces of melted rubber
that are still on fire.
It's like a mini firework show.
[Music]
Every single layer is just
pulling off into hot--
Alright,
don't stand that close.
[Music]
They are actually
hitting Nate's coat
while he's working.
They're not on fire,
but they were hitting him.
[Music]
Now initially, I wanted
to try this project
because this is
how golf balls used to be made.
They used to have
a thick rubber core,
and then they would wind rubber
bands around it before putting
on that plastic shell.
Now, some may still
be made like that,
but most of them aren't.
So making a rubber band ball is
another really good way to kind
of see that reaction of tossing
a golf ball in a fire,
which some people have done.
I've heard about it,
so I wanted to see
what would happen.
[Music]
Guys, that's all
we've got for you today,
but the fun doesn't end there.
If you hit that box
up at the top,
it will take you
to our latest video.
The box at the bottom
will take you to
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
And if you hit this bomb
in the middle,
you'll be subscribe,
so you never miss
out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.